on
[Musique]
massa
non
[Musique]
à
bonjour bienvenue pour ce numéro spécial
de mode d'emploi nous sommes au
vélodrome nationale à l'occasion de
l'événement en piste pour l'emploi c'est
le rendez vous de saint quentin en
yvelines dédié à l'emploi et à la
formation
focus justement sur l'évolution
professionnelle tout de suite nous
allons parler apprentissage et
alternance avec vous sabine barré alors
vous êtes développeur de l'apprentissage
territoriales dans le sud yvelines
oui est-ce que vous pouvez nous
présenter votre vision donc en fait mon
poste est prise en charge par le conseil
régional d'ile-de-france qui me demande
de faire la promotion de l'apprentissage
de faire le lien sur le territoire entre
toutes les structures pour faciliter
l'accès des jeunes à l'apprentissage
donc je sais pas si je vous parle tout
de suite de l'apprentissage oui oui
c'est vrai que l'on entend beaucoup
parler notamment ce moment avec le
gouvernement sans les grands chantiers
du gouvernement
justement pour y voir plus clair plus
muller ckoi l'apprenti ça alors
l'apprentissage c'est vrai que c'est une
façon différente de ceux formés qui est
accessible pour les jeunes uniquement
entre 15 et 30 ans et qui permet du coup
une façon différente puisque on va
alterner des périodes en entreprise avec
des périodes en centre de formation ce
qui fait qu'on va acquérir de
l'expérience tout en se formant donc la
formation bien sûr est gratuite et
rémunérée et ce qui est vraiment génial
dans l'apprentissage c'est qu'on va
s'immerger progressivement dans
l'entreprise et bien sûr être
opérationnel très rapidement et du fait
trouver du boulot enfin de lui un emploi
à l'issue de l'apprentissage vraiment
bien plus rapidement que qu'une personne
qui aura fait les mêmes diplômes parce
que ce sont les mêmes diplômes mais
cette fois à temps plein de façon
classique et encore pas si longtemps on
disait souvent que l'apprentissage
l'alternance est un petit peu une voie
de garage
vous avez un petit peu mauvaise presse
est ce que quand même cette image est en
train de changer
malheureusement c'est encore long et je
trouve que c'est encore compliqué c'est
à dire que les parents sont très
réfractaires à l'apprentissage pense
qu'effectivement que quand ils envoient
leurs jeunes dans un bac pro dans une
formation en apprentissage
ça va être pour eux une voie de garage
ils pourront pas continuer alors que
c'est tout le contraire puisque ils
auront au contraire accès à tous les
mêmes diplômes c'est à dire jusqu'au
master comme les autres et la différence
c'est qu'ils auront une expérience
professionnelle qui vont valoriser et
donc on voit des parcours magnifiques de
jeunes qui trouvent un emploi
contrairement aux autres qui ont
beaucoup de mal parce que quand ils
arrivent devant un employeur qui n'ont
pas d'expérience malheureusement c'est
très compliqué de trouver un emploi et
justement juste à côté de vous
christopher beauval bonjour vous êtes en
deuxième année de bts siao ses filles de
montigny le bretonneux le cfi pour ceux
qui ne connaîtraient pas c'est l'école
connecté au futur de l'industrie à leur
bts siao déjà ça veut dire quoi alors
ces systèmes informatiques aux
organisations c'est donc une formation
en alternance et puisque vous êtes donc
une semaine à l'école une semaine à
l'afnic avec votre vote tuteur qui est
juste à côté on parlera évidemment de
l'afnic dans quelques instants
juste avant est ce que christopher
pouvez nous en dire plus sur votre sur
votre parcours
alors moi j'ai commencé avec un bac sen
systèmes électroniques numériques
j'ai voulu me diriger vers cette
formation parce que je voulais pas aller
en général j'étais dès le collège
mais passionné par l'informatique donc
j'ai voulu une diriger vers cette
filière là c'est pour ça que après mon
bac j'ai eu
voulu continuer vers la formation
toujours dans l'informatique et donc
c'est pour ça que je tombais sur la
formation ici et l'alternance c'était
c'était vous en aviez déjà entendu
parler avant seulement après la mission
apb en fait j'en ai pas forcément
entendu parler avant
c'est surtout en dernière année qu'on
nous en parle beaucoup pas forcément à
l'arrivée de notre formation
sabine barry aurait un manque du coup
d'information justement oui oui c'est un
gros problème on a du mal à moi c'est
moche c'est mon boulot d'essayer de
rentrer dans les collèges et lycées pour
expliquer à chaque élève qu'il a le
choix dans la poursuite de ses études
que ce choix existent qui correspond pas
forcément à tout le monde parce que
c'est vrai que l'apprentissage
contrairement à ce qu'on disait c'est
pas fait pour les nuls parce qu'au
contraire il faut mener de front la
formation et l'emploi
et c'est vrai que malheureusement il ya
des objectifs au sein de l'éducation
nationale de faire rentrer les jeunes
dans les filières générales et pas dans
les filières professionnelles et ce qui
fait que j'avoue qu'on a du mal à
communiquer auprès des jeunes qui quand
on trouvait enfin la solution de
l'apprentissage re découvre un autre
monde puisque là ils vont vraiment être
bien plus motivés ils vont comprendre à
quoi ça sert ce qu'ils apprennent et
même éventuellement se réorienter au fil
du temps un jeune qui va partir en
commerce va tout d'un coup se rendre
compte que finalement c'est les
ressources humaines qui lui plaisent
parce qu'il l'est dans l'entreprise et
qui peut vraiment voir en quoi ça
consiste que ça reste pas du vent quoi
il voit vraiment ce qu'il fait et il
applique ce qu'il apprend en cours et
c'est vrai que c'est très différent
vous faites votre votre formation donc à
l'afnic depuis depuis le début on
parlera évidemment de vos missions
justement dans cette entreprise juste à
côté de vous jean michel behra fatto
bonjour vous êtes responsable identi au
sein de cette association responsable a
insi alors je souhaite pour sa de la
ferme infrastructures et technologies
l'afnic est en fait ma mission
déjà vous présentez l'afnic voilà parce
que c'est une association une
association l'association française pour
le nommage internet en coopération et
notre mission une de nos missions ces
opérateurs de multi registre est tout
particulièrement le point fr ont fait
fonctionner le point fr au quotidien
voilà c'est nos missions principales
c'est une branche de
de l'inria el ainaine une branche de
l'inria et là on vient de fêter ses 20
ans voilà cette base et à montigny est
ce que vous accueillir régulièrement des
alternants alors oui on accueille
régulièrement des alternants
en fait c'est un c'est un vecteur de
gier et de transfert de partage
d'informations et de partage de
compétences auprès des auprès des
alternants pour nous c'est important que
cet échange ait lieu avec le tissu local
parce que
bon
ben voilà christopher par exemple au
quotidien il est amené à être proche des
équipes techniques avec lesquels il
travaille
il va vous pouvoir vous donner plus de
détails sur ce qu'il fait mais
concrètement
très vite des clients dans une équipe de
production informatique dès qu'il ya des
vous êtes combien de combien de salariés
à l'avenir les 80 salariés
environ ce qui nous un pas dans le
service où il est on est confronté un
parfois des sujets techniques et il peut
se retrouver à être informés ou à savoir
être être au courant de certaines
certains points techniques et certains
sujets
qu'ils le feront monter en compétences
pour plus tard c'est pas la première
fois qu'on a un échange avec des
apprentis qui reviennent après en disant
j'ai appris beaucoup et ça m'a donné
avec ça va donner des chances pour
pouvoir me faire embaucher derrière et
voilà alors christopher quelles sont vos
missions à l'afnic a alors moi je suis
dans l'haïti haïti qui est séparé entre
guillemets entre plusieurs groupes les
administrateurs les architectes et moi
je suis à l'assistance utilisateurs
tout est dans le nom en fait moi ma
mission c'est d'assister les
utilisateurs dans l'assistance au
quotidien des membres de l'afnic en fait
voilà c'est ça d'accord donc tous les
jours c'est sympa vote une journée type
par exemple à l'afnic c'est quoi une
journée type
dès le matin à quelqu'un qui me voient
qui me dit j'ai un problème avec mon
ordi par exemple et moi je dois résoudre
le problème
ça peut être différentes tâches ont fait
une nouvelle personne qui arrive à
l'afnic préparer son poste et c'est tout
le quotidien enfants dans gêne aussi
c'est ans alors monsieur perrin photo il
est comment christopher justement dans
votre entreprise
christopher est à 100% quand il a
entreprise avec nous et il est investi
et
comment vous dire ben il est il est
présent voilà il est présent il est
guidé au pot en fait il a appris à être
proche des utilisateurs
au début ils étaient un peu bas ils
sortaient des études dont qui l'était
pas il n'avait pas encore l'habitude
d'aller voir les gens et au fur et à
mesure déjà en fait si demain il cherche
un boulot il sera déjà ce que ça veut
dire d'être au service des autres et
d'être de travail dans une entreprise
et c'est là ça c'est un message clé
quand on arrive à ce concert des études
les goûts moi j'ai connu quand j'ai fait
mes études il ya très longtemps on
n'avait pas ce sont ces éléments là qui
permettait de d'apprendre à vivre en
entreprise à part les stages de fin
d'année au der en dernière année
d'études mais c'est tout dans dix
classes et bien parce que c'est tout le
long et la personne qu'on qui arrive
enfin il quand il va arriver en
entreprise dans une future entreprise il
aura déjà une expérience de premier
contact avec une entreprise de ben faut
se lever faut aller voir les gens font
leur part les feux qu'est ce que tu fais
alors attends je vais t'aider
le travailler ensemble le travail
ensemble c'est important justement vous
parlez la suite sabine baril quel est le
taux d'insertion professionnelle quand
on fait un apprentissage ou en
alternance
les statistiques sont que sept jeunes
sur 10 trouvent un emploi à l'issue de
l'apprentissage
et c'est vrai que c'est à tous les
niveaux un ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure ça va du ceap et au masters et
on s'aperçoit que les jeunes étudiants
dont qui sont dans des niveaux plus
élevés ont bien compris que
l'apprentissage c'est ce qui allait leur
donner du boulot donc on voit souvent
des jeunes qui traînaient dans des facs
à faire des masters à n'en plus finir
qu'il n'était plus reconnaît enfin qu'il
n'était pas connectée avec l'entreprise
en fait et qui du coup viennent vers
l'apprentissage en se disant ben voilà
ça va être ma solution pour trouver du
boulot quoi c'est vraiment ce qu'on
disait exactement un employeur est
rassuré quand il voit sur un cv qu'un
jeune a fait une formation
d'apprentissage il sait que le jeune
connaît déjà le monde du travail et qui
va être employables immédiatement et ça
change tout pour le pour un une embauche
oui un désavantage un autre avantage
aussi c'est qu'on est payé quand on sait
qu'une alternance exactement les
apprentis sont rémunérés donc c'est en
fonction de leur âge et en fonction de
l'année
dans laquelle ils sont en apprentissage
et c'est vrai que le gouvernement il
travaille actuellement sur la réforme de
l'apprentissage est effectivement cette
rémunération va être évaluée et on a
prévu de vraiment favoriser
l'apprentissage et du coup d'augmenter
cette rémunération qui a du coup un
ordre d'idée donc évidemment c'est
sauver leur âge mais oui alors un jeune
de mineurs qui commence en première
année d'apprentissage va toucher environ
ses 25 % du smic donc le 380 euros
quelque chose comme ça et enfin si les
s'il est dans la fourchette d'âge la
plus élevée donc c'est il va toucher 75
% du smic mais le mille 1000 milles
euros à peu près christopher est ce que
vous pouvez un petit peu quelqu'un parle
de pâques et peut-être dans dans le
public plutôt des parents peut-être
qu'ils se posent encore des questions
justement sur sur l'alternance pour
leurs enfants qu'est ce que vous
pourriez dire en fait pour justement
dire bah pour voilà pour les pour les
convaincre peut-être pas moi
l'alternance elle m'a permis de gagner
en maturité je dirais en indépendance
financière aussi il faut le savoir c'est
l'alternance c'est très utile à ce
niveau là aussi en autonomie beaucoup
d'autonomie enfin l'alternance
en gros elle permet d'appliquer la
partie théorique dans la pratique voilà
allier la théorie et la pratique
permettent de gagner aussi en confiance
on il ya beaucoup davantage dans
l'alternance une conclusion peut-être
chacun bas
pour l'afnic ça s'arrête pas là c'est à
dire que bon nous on recrute des
apprentis
un christopher va finir par exemple son
cursus dans pas longtemps et donc on va
reprendre certainement un apprenti nous
pour nous c'est important de transmettre
et puis de pouvoir partager quand
l'occasion se présente pour pouvoir
embaucher quelqu'un derrière on le fait
mais là pour le coup bang et ofer veut
continuer ses études après derrière donc
ya pas de problème mais pour moi le mot
de conclusion c'est c'est vraiment bien
de faire se soucier de ce système
d'apprentissage parce que c'est un plus
pour l'entreprise parce qu on est proche
des étudiants et en même temps on
partage on se met à l écoute des
étudiants et eux apprennent de nous et
du coup ils sont poussés plus facile
pour eux pour entrer dans le monde de
l'entreprise
sabine barret bah moi je voudrais redire
un peu ce que j'ai dit qu'on va rassurer
vraiment tout le monde en se disant que
ce n'est pas du tout une voie de garage
au contraire quoi qu'il faut vraiment
pas avoir peur de l'apprentissage convoi
des cursus formidable de jeunes qui sont
partis d'un ca paix et qui sont allés
jusqu'au master vraiment serré on le
voit régulièrement quoi donc ne pas et
on l'a peut-être pas faire pas forcément
10 mai tous les secteurs d'activité en
plus 500 sont concernées vrai c'est vrai
tous les secteurs d'activité il faut pas
penser qu'aux métiers manuels d'artisans
etc
il ya vraiment tous les secteurs la
preuve l'informatique la chimie
l'industrie
qu'est-ce que j'ai d'autres comme idée
mais vraiment tous les métiers à paris
face surtout nous sur la région ile de
france on est très riche en centre de
formation d'apprentis
non vraiment n'ayez pas peur de
l'apprentissage merci en tout cas à tous
les trois nous avoir apporté votre votre
témoignage sur sur l'apprentissage et
l'alternance merci
[Musique]
oh
si vous êtes salarié dans une entreprise
par exemple eh bien il existe plusieurs
dispositifs vous avez certainement
entendu parler de vae de bilan de
compétences ou encore de compte
personnel de formation
eh bien il faut savoir que ces
formations sont financées par les opca
les autres cas ce sont les organismes
paritaires collecteurs agréés et
justement avec noah grégory chevron
bonjour bonjour alors vous vous êtes
conseiller formation chez opcalia je
parlais d'opca quelle est la différence
entre eux un opca et opcalia opcalia est
un autre cas interprofessionnel qui a la
particularité de s'occuper à la fois
deux branches professionnelles
spécifiques mais aussi la particularité
de pouvoir prendre des entreprises qui
n'ont pas de branches professionnelles
donc il y a dans les acteurs de la
formation 18 opca 16 opca de branche et
deux autres cas interprofessionnelle
donc il faut savoir que ocalia est l'un
des deux autres cas interprofessionnelle
nous avons quand même une plus d'une
trentaine de branches dans lequel nous
occupons et donc la particularité de
l'opca interprofessionnelle c'est de
pouvoir travailler avec des entreprises
qui peuvent aussi bien déjà avoir un
opca de branche travaillé sur la partie
libre mais travaillait que les
entreprises dont les partenaires sociaux
n'ont pas défini un opca de branche
spécifique
donc vous voyez qu'on accompagne
énormément de pme et nous collectons pas
loin de 600 millions d'euros
votre mission c'est bien de collecter
justement les cotisations des
entreprises enseignants là à l'organisme
paritaire collecteur agréé alors la
collecte fait partie intégrante de notre
travail mais le grand plus c'est
d'accompagner les entreprises dans
lesquelles vous travaillez sur leur
projet de formation
donc là je vous ai vu quelques exemples
de branches professionnelles si vous
travaillez dans ses branches
professionnelles forcément vous dépendez
de l'opcalia est donc de notre
accompagnement
alors du coup comment ça fonctionne
concrètement en fait alors l'entreprise
au mois de février est obligé de verser
1 % de sa masse salariale bien sûr elle
verse 1 % et vous allez me dire très
bien moi je travaille dans l'entreprise
mais je sais pas trop finalement ce
qu'on en fait c'est 1%
donc c'est pas forcément très compliqué
mais très simple non plus selon la
taille de votre entreprise les
cotisations se répartissent de
différentes manières et dans différentes
enveloppes
donc vous voyez pour les entreprises de
moins de 10 celle plus simple puisque
c'est 0 55 % de la masse salariale et ça
vous donne un budget de formation pour
toutes les entreprises identique après
selon la taille de votre entreprise
il y a des répartitions et des
arbitrages qui sont faits donc si on
prend un exemple d'une contribution de 1
% des entreprises vous voyez que opcalia
va en garder 60% et va redonner 40%
donc le fpspp c'est le fonds paritaire
de sécurisation des parcours
professionnels ou nous reversons une
partie du 1 % de votre entreprise à cet
organisme
nous reversons aussi 20% des 20% que
verse votre employeur au fongecif pour
faire le congé individuel de formation
mais aussi le bilan de compétences et la
vae qu'on oublie souvent et donc nous
avons à votre disposition à une
enveloppe qui représente 60% du montant
donc la première enveloppe celle
enveloppe de la professionnalisation que
vous voyez en bas à gauche pour laquelle
votre employeur
va pouvoir réaliser des contrats de
professionnalisation c'est comme vous
l'avez vu auparavant il ya les contrats
d'apprentissage à ce jour opcalia et les
autres cas gère les contrats de
professionnalisation est ce qu'on peut
dire que vous jouez finalement un rôle
central dans les landes dans
l'élaboration des plans de formation
oui plus nous travaillons plus les opca
travail en général un peu plus avec les
drh les responsables formation que les
salariés pour cause l'entreprise nous
confie ses fonds et à partir de là on
travaille sur le plan de formation pour
optimiser au maximum le rendement
financier entre autres donc vous avez
les des coûts de prise en charge par
exemple sur le club de la
professionnalisation que je vous ai mis
à titre à titre d'exemple alors voilà
aussi quelques exemples que nous pouvons
financer sur les demandes de cpf des
salariés le permis b en finance de la
vae des bilans de compétences les
formations certifiantes et des taux
unique entre autres c'est en général ce
qui sort le plus justement c'est ce que
je vais vous demander qu'est-ce qui est
qu'est-ce qui est le plus demandé les
formations l'angle est permis dakar sont
à ce jour
après donc dans les yvelines on est bien
d'accord dans les yvelines
j'adorerais national national alors
après l'opca a aussi d'autres missions
qui est d'aller chercher des fonds
soient régionaux du fonds social
européen des fonds d'état pour essayer
d'optimiser selon des thématiques bien
précises
le budget de plantes formation de votre
entreprise il ya des cursus qui font
qu'on peut optimiser au maximum son plan
de formation et être accompagnée de
manière qualitative par un opca par
opcalia puisque nous avons aussi nous
certifions certains organismes de
formations pour lesquelles nous créons
des sessions de formation collective
avec des dates précises et selon la
taille de l'entreprise nous avons des
tarifs négociés prêt négocié et nous
pouvons financer jusqu'à 100 % du coût
pédagogique des actions collectives
donc voilà c'est toujours bien se
renseigner sur l'accompagnement de
l'opca de votre entreprise
parce que normalement il est du coup
voilà les salariés se rapprochent se
rapproche de qui justement pour en
savoir systématiquement du chef
d'entreprise puisque le plan de
formation est vraiment à la main de
l'entreprise
on ne peut pas demander à imposer à
l'entreprise de dire voilà je veux faire
ça vous me le nom si vous souhaitez
faire votre formation et yale cpf pour
lesquelles vous gérez vos heures après
l'employeur lui avec son 1 % des sites d
action stratégique à mener ou non sur
son entreprise ce qu'il faut quand même
noter pour conclure c'est que nous
sommes en phase de transition puisque il
ya un projet de loi sur la réforme de la
formation professionnelle qui va être
déposée très certainement mi-avril avec
énormément de changements dont le plus
notable serait éventuellement puisque
rien n'est fait ainsi les absolument pas
officielle mais éventuellement une
monétarisation du cpf avec une
application fin 2019 qui permettra aux
salles actions aux salariés pardon de
passer directement via l'application
pour faire cesser de bande de formation
et puis tout l'univers des opca qui
changerait de nom et
et plein d'autres choses mais on est
bien et fait encore merci en tout cas
grégory chevron d'être intervenu sur ce
sujet je rappelle que vous êtes
conseiller formation chez opcalia
[Musique]
c'est la fin de ce numéro merci de
l'avoir suivi à très bientôt pour un
nouveau mode d'emploi
[Musique]